tract l'antique le candidat à la maison
blanche joe biden a dénoncé un attentat
terrible il a promis de travailler avec
les alliés s'ils étaient élus et un peu
plus tôt c'est le président américain
donald trump qui réagissait il est en
pleine campagne pour la présidentielle
du 3 novembre prochain il a tenu à
apporter son soutien au peuple français
les détails avec notre envoyé spécial à
new york stefani de mary donald trump
est en meeting en floride aujourd'hui et
c'est par un tweet qui a décidé de
réagir le président américain a écouté
nos coeurs sont avec le peuple français
l'amérique est aux côtés de notre plus
ancien allié dans ce combat ces attaques
terroristes islamiques radicales doivent
cesser immédiatement
aucun pays france ou autre ne peut le
supporter plus longtemps
le président américain qui fait donc
allusion à la france son plus vieil
allié dans ce combat oubliées donc les
rancunes américaine lorsqu au lendemain
des attentats du 1er septembre 2001 on
s'en souvient jacques chirac avait reçu
refusé de se tenir aux côtés des états
unis dans son invasion de l'irak
il faut dire que la france et les états
unis collaborent effectivement toujours
dans cette lutte contre l'islamisme
coalision anti des ch au moyen-orient
alors que donald trump avait pourtant
fait comme promesse de campagne de se
retirer de se désengager du moyen-orient
en 2018 on se souvient en décembre il
avait provoqué une levée de boucliers en
annonçant son désengagement total de la
syrie avant de faire volte face
finalement il y a toujours un millier
dom américains sur place en syrie il y a
deux mois également annonce de la
réduction des troupes américaines dans
cette lutte un comme une anti des shows
moyen-orient en irak
cette fois faisant passer ses troupes de
5200 à 3000 alors ce débat ces tensions
autour des caricatures de mahomet
diffusées dans la presse en france est
ce que cela pourrait arriver aux états
unis et bien en théorie oui et non
puisque vous le savez les états unis
sont extrêmement attachés à la liberté
d'expression avec ce sacro sainte
première amendement de loi d'expression
liberté de la presse ce qui finalement
exclu un délit de blasphème mais il faut
noter qu'en 2015 lors de l' affaire des
caricatures de mahomet en france les
médias américains avaient finalement
très peu repris ses dessins jugés
blessants pour la communauté musulmane
peut être aussi pour ne pas me mettre de
l'huile sur le feu